donc bienvenue dans ce journal
officiellement c'est un ajournement de
fait cela ressemble bien à un
enterrement le gouvernement a donc
décidé de renoncer à la taxe carbone
c'est françois fillon qui l'a annoncé
aujourd'hui elle n'aura donc pas survécu
à la défaite des régionales romain mais
si sébastien laffargue l'ordre jour
officiellement elle n'est pas enterrée
mais la taxe carbone c'est une certitude
n'entrera pas en vigueur le 1er juillet
prochain c'est ce que françois fillon a
annoncé aujourd'hui aux députés à ne pas
des décisions que nous allons prendre en
matière de développement durable doivent
être mieux coordonnées avec l'ensemble
des pays européens pour ne pas creuser
le déficit de compétitivité avec notre
voisin allemand en clair tout dépendra
donc d'un accord à vingt-sept hypothèse
peu probable
la taxe carbone devait être pourtant un
temps fort de la présidence sarkozy
après la signature du pacte écologique
de nicolas hulot après le grenelle de
l'environnement michel rocard remet tait
l'été dernier ses propositions pour une
taxe sur les émissions de co2 jean louis
borloo en faisait alors la promotion
l'idée générale c'est que c'est bon pour
le pouvoir d'achat des ménages c'est ça
qu'il faut retenir début septembre
nicolas sarkozy tranche la taxe carbone
entrera en vigueur dès le 1er janvier
2010 ça fait trop d'années qu'on
repousse à demain les décisions qu'il
faut prendre maintenant quelques jours
plus tard face aux députés ump nicolas
sarkozy évoque même un choix historique
comparable à l'abolition de la peine de
mort mais à la veille du jour de l'an
coup de théâtre le conseil
constitutionnel censure le projet de loi
retour à la case départ mais à droite
l'opposition à la taxe carbone est de
plus en plus forte avant même les
élections régionales nicolas sarkozy
envisage un changement de cap
la défaite enfonce le clou le
gouvernement fait aujourd'hui marche
arrière la gauche crie au scandale
président de la république n'a pas de
parole je sais pas si c'est une bonne
nouvelle voilà puisque c'est ça la seule
nouvelle ils l'avaient promis ils
s'étaient engagés à renoncer satisfait
simplement une petite partie de son
électorat c'est pas une réforme c'est
l'abandon de nouvelles formes une
décision qui fait des remous au sein
même du gouvernement chantal jouanno
secrétaire d'état à l'écologie déclare
ce soir je suis désespérée de ce recul
désespérée que ce soit
l'écolo-scepticisme qui l'emportent je
ne suis pas en phase avec cette décision
nicolas sarkozy devrait s'en expliquer
demain en conseil des ministres